so there's some debate about whether or
not orcs must die Unchained is a MOBA
now i'm not a big MOBA player so i'm not
in the best position to determine
whether the various elements that
comprise orcs must die unchain make the
game ova or not and in the end I'm not
sure it matters when I got to play
unchanged last week in advance of the
games beta my feeling was that it's a
more accessible game than something like
League of Legends our dota while still
having enough facets to allow for deep
rewarding tactical play it probably
helped my experience that I spent most
of my time playing as blackpaw a
powerful and agile offensive hero with
whom I could confidently leap into the
fray and deal damage to enemy minions
and players
unlike in a traditional MOBA minions
aren't generic units that are
automatically generated and sent or the
enemy base instead each team has war
camps where you play cards from your
deck to determine what types of minions
are sent forth minions have all kinds of
different characteristics some are pure
damage dealers others disable traps
others heal and putting together a more
effective combination of minions than
the opposing team is important since
victory goes to the first team that gets
20 minions into the rift in the opposing
teams fortress
as you play you earn leadership points
which can either be poured into
upgrading existing war camps enabling
them to send out more powerful minions
or into opening up new war camps
allowing you to assault the enemy team
down multiple lanes on the defensive
side there's the traditional orcs must
die element of traps you can spend gold
you earn during the match on traps
designed to prevent enemy minions from
getting anywhere near your rift and
placing traps like choosing minions is a
tactical concern because certain types
of traps work better against certain
types of minions the action moves fast
and between offense/defense setting
traps choosing minions and upgrading war
camps there's a lot to think about I had
fun during the three matches I played
but whether these elements make
unchained a game that can stand out in
the increasingly crowded world of
competitive online games remains to be
seen the game is in beta now so if you
want a shot at checking it out for
yourself you can go to the official site
and sign up
I